[Music]
guys let me tell you
about this girl named claire tell us
oh claire i remember only known hot
clears
much what i've only known hot claire's
very hot claire's i got my ears pierced
at claire's hey y'all
yeah well let me tell you about claire
so she's 22 years old
she's one of four women amongst
60 men in a graduate science and finance
program at the university of iowa what
is happening
claire's he got his ears pierced
declares that's [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
because of his hail no because that's
like where 12 year old girls go to get
like ice
yeah to get plastic ice uh yeah
yeah it's not funny at all that we
should move on what is it called a
stationary
i just need to know like how did that
happen like you go we went to a mall and
you were like
hi i would like to get my ears literally
everyone would get their ears preset
claire's
what do you guys think no is he sure
they were pierced because they could
have been stick-ons like i don't know
no i got my ears per second i think i
did too they use a gun huh yeah
it's like super like cheap and
professional and i i mean at 18 i was
like
i don't know any like i don't know i
don't know where to go you have to
defend yourself literally everyone got
their ears personal yes
it's not it's not that funny we should
have walkers
anyway god claire i'm so relating to you
even more now
anyway so claire she was on a video call
for a commercial underwriting group
project
and so she began recording herself
because her male classmates were
repeatedly interrupting her
and dismissing her here we go here this
is why you picked this article
okay we get it [ __ ] yes so
so at first she said that she only meant
to send it to her video
this video to a friend and another and
and another woman in the program
but then she ended up watching the video
back and she just thought it was such a
great example of how often this happens
to women and male dominated
in a male 1 let me speak for you really
quick because i agree
and i think that men should stop
interrupting that's right
and because you know why i think that
men should stop learning
male dominated industries yeah and then
also
no okay here's the video okay
well that's not i don't have a mortgage
either so that's different
different you could be you know the
whole sticky customer thing makes more
sense for a mortgage because it's so
long term
yeah i mean these are my no i i i think
the deliverables is
uh so yeah yeah we would try to get a
good explanation
so kind of like yeah we need to use
um data mining basically i don't know
but if we want to
if we want to um in our data mining i
think that we need to focus more on the
customer specific data
rather than the zip code um so
because we want to really break down
input no so if it's empty means no bank
selling at she wasn't saying anything
that interesting and i just felt i
couldn't wait for her to get cut off
you um i've noticed okay when i listen
to women
speaking together right they don't cut
themselves off but they can all speak
simultaneously and they can all listen
right um when guys talk to each other
depending on what kind of guy you're
around some guys just talk and they
don't [ __ ] listen
yep yep yep yep yep so she ended up
saying that she has worked in commercial
underwriting for
years she is the most experienced out of
anyone in this group she has the
assignment that was given was literally
the exact same thing that she did in
that role that she's had
for years so the fact that they were
just dismissing her and not even like
and just saying no yeah and and just
talking over her and so she ended up
captioning this
live footage of women of a woman in stem
so in case you don't know stem means
science to technology
and engineering mathematics right so
it's like any
any industry in that field i thought
stem guys were just all socially dumb
and they all don't know how to have
conversations and like listen and [ __ ]
oh that's right
dude crypto guys are the same they're
like there's been
countless dudes that just [ __ ] talk
and they don't shut the [ __ ]
up and you're like dude remember when
snowden was on joe rogan
and everyone's like my god will joe
rogan ever be able to talk again
because snowden's such a [ __ ] nerd
that he couldn't shut the [ __ ] up even
neil degrasse tyson
yeah he was like talking over joe rogan
he just kept going and going and going
and going
yeah presidential debate just that
either sorry baby it's not just that
either it happens the other way around
here
that's why i apologize which is
something you [ __ ] will never
do
anyway when you say you [ __ ]
that's hurtful by the way that's hurt
anthony because he's actually apologized
when he interrupted i'm sorry baby
i've never [ __ ] i've never [ __ ] a
mom i know this guy [ __ ] him all
the time but yeah he's such a
[ __ ] he is though
okay anyway so then she was also
elaborating a little bit more she said
there will be
there would be an assignment that we the
other stem
women would help other classmates with
and they would take credit for it
if we present an idea whether it's
theoretical or any type of opinion
it's always like they're very hesitant
to believe it and if they do believe it
then they take
credit like i already knew that i
already knew that and then they'll
repeat it to other people and claim it
as their own
wow [ __ ] copyrighting [ __ ]
yeah you guys are [ __ ] plagiarists
yeah so then hold on but it's not even
the stem field though
because this [ __ ] went viral on tick
tock because of the fact that
so many women in so many industries
literally so many women can relate to
this [ __ ]
so it was just really relatable to a lot
of people so why is it that women can't
say interesting things
yeah it's like like what stops them yeah
what stops that problem stopping guys
from actually listening to a woman are
saying
what was that wait what's that wow
that's called coordination she also said
that you know what actually
so this part so there was this one
person that commented on that and then
they said
um literally keep talking do not stutter
do not pause
because if they aren't saying anything
keep talking until they realize that
they've interrupted you i have
unknowingly done this
after years in this position and that
[ __ ] works girls do that just keep
talking don't let them talk
that's all guys thoughts what trump did
to biden and just do that she literally
i encouraged girls to do that because
girls are they actually listen so when
they hear somebody talking they'll like
wait
wrong and like yeah you got to do what
trump does because
when you see guys going at it on a
decision or something right
they'll talk simultaneously and they'll
just try to win and that's
literally the difference bulldozing
that's that's the thing
yeah and i don't think that it's wrong
for women to do it just [ __ ] do it
because all of us are doing it
right but when you're too [ __ ]
respectful and you sit there and you
listen and all that
you're not going to get your points of a
decent human being yeah i guess you're
not going to get your point across
but it's not a guy thing it's just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing
i know chicks would [ __ ] take way too
long to get to the point okay but then
but like i don't know like i think if a
girl were to interject with the guy like
the guy would probably call her a [ __ ]
so it's like a weird stuff seriously
we have that [ __ ] we interrupt all the
time and like and we're talking over a
guy and the guy wants to make his point
across and then we like
[ __ ] [ __ ] calling a woman a [ __ ]
she has to really be a [ __ ] though she
can't just be like she just interrupt
dudes all the time exactly
it's gonna be really big it's really
difficult to contribute to this
conversation
you're a decent human being hey dude
it's okay we cut
you know you feel when you feel it
yeah it sucks though because i feel like
the communication styles
are definitely different yes so because
of that
like it is tougher because i think that
well in general women are more
collaborative they don't
compete and men are constantly competing
it's a dick measuring contest
so when you're thrown into that space
like
who's trying to win the position and all
that
it's it's an underlying thing that's
happening so the style of
what's going on is way different from
what they're used to i don't know i mean
i also think women compete with each
other too
yeah i i think it's a behavioral thing
though because i don't think it's a
gender thing
i feel like there's a lot of men that
are respectful too and they'll wait
their turn to talk and
those men are i guess if you had to sum
it up be like they'd be considered
debatable
and they don't get their dick sucked
ever by these chicks you know the alphas
okay though like can you adjust when you
observe it right
so instead of like expecting them to
bend to you you try to compete in
overpowering right if you have a point
to say and you have to get it across
then yeah that's
that's when you have to choose to step
up to the plate and get your point
across but that's the most annoying
thing though is because most people
like most men usually when they're
speaking they're not even
listening they're just trying to figure
out the next thing to say to rebuttal to
the thing that the person
the other person is saying so there's no
listening happening
it's a very convenient uh point you made
but i gotta say
what no no no you mean it's a fact
that she pointed out it's an easy color
to just paint on somebody but
but if you're a socially awkward person
i'm not saying i am but i'm saying if
you're a man you're a socially awkward
person
and you have your talking points like
measured out in your head and like this
is what i got to say
and like i don't want to be awkward and
all this [ __ ] then you're just going to
keep on hitting those things so there's
there's a lot more nuance to all of this
than any of us is acknowledging right
like we don't know necessarily if the
person that's doing it is doing it
because you're a woman
and we don't know if it's he's a social
idiot
and all he has is those points and then
if you go he's doing it because he's a
man
it is an easy shortcut answer well hold
on
it's not just that it's also you got to
take the the entire situation from
her like this one particular instance
with it with
she's not wrong by the way so it's the
fact that like the sexist part comes in
where
they're telling the women in the group
like oh i already knew that and then
they go and [ __ ] use their ideas and
not credit them and then there's like
stealing
stealing all these ideas because they
want to come off like they're smart and
then also like downplaying
the more experienced woman in this whole
situation it's just like
that happens way too often i think that
that would be sexism right there yeah
that's how
sexist and dude you have to remember too
the backstory of this and i'm just doing
this because i want to get laid later
like um the backstory of this is like
chicks can't even tell nicki so you're
good no no no
just cut that part okay so chicks can't
even go
get a car on their own without the guy
who's at the dealership being like uh
you know like do you want your husband
here and all this kind of [ __ ]
no all the time all the time literally
so many things on the deed of our home
like i
i was the first signer and then casey
was the second sign but then as
we get our our mortgage bills it's
casey's name
only not even me so many times like the
guy waiter brings the bill and he puts
it in front of me like
i seen it i'm not an idiot so i notice
it but i want to get laid so that's why
i'm saying it
and and so it's it's frustrating it's
very frustrating that's what you want me
to say right are not
[Laughter]
while we're having this discussion my
points are not to either discredit or
rebut
or i mean uh argue the fact that this
doesn't happen
all i'm saying is it is a very shortcut
answer to say
because you are a man you do x yeah well
i also agree it's not that black and
white though i'm not we're i'm not
saying
it's that black and white right right
but then it we have to be careful about
these kind of
situations because people really do
believe this kind of stuff
they go because you're a man you don't
respect women and here's evidence for
that
yeah that's not right right it's not
right to blanket it no no not at all
but i'm not trying to say that but we do
have to look into this situation and go
why does this phenomenon happen because
i'm not a i'm not
saying that it doesn't happen it happens
clearly women get disrespected or talked
over whatever it happens right
but then now it now the question is how
do
why does it happen and and and just by
saying
oh it happens because men don't respect
women that doesn't answer or solve the
problem all it says is just like it
happens because men are mean
versus going okay this happens because
for example this specific situation
let's say it is a sexist incident
this guy doesn't you know respect her
thoughts because he thinks that women
are below him
then we can attack that situation and go
why doesn't he believe
that women are on the same playing field
because of what reasons
right he might believe that women don't
have a strong left brain way of thinking
because if you look at the classroom
it's all meant or whatever the reason is
you got to dissect that individual's
biases
or maybe it's a group bias whatever but
if we don't get to that point and we
just blanket it
it doesn't solve anything and that's
what i hate about today's society where
it's very like
so simple men are bad because you're
mean to women
whatever here's 30 seconds of evidence
therefore
my bias is affirmed exactly because it
could be like he's a social
idiot and he just talks over everyone
dude
you heard vitalik buterin talk he's the
guy who did ethereum ethereal crypto
guys
he'll never be able to not do what we're
hearing right now but it's not because
he hates women or any of that kind of
[ __ ] he just
doesn't know how to [ __ ] not say what
he's thinking
as soon as you ask him a question so and
he can't stop
and so snowden's the same way and
there's some people who just have
certain things about them that they
can't stop
answering the question it would be
unfortunate if they're all males though
then the that sounds kind of sometimes
like it seems like
according to the response to this thing
it's like a lot of people relate to that
okay but true but also when you think
about oscar speeches okay
who gets played off the most it's the
guys damn it okay oh okay
yep we're gonna go to the drawing board
we're gonna cut all that
and we're gonna go to the drawing board
and we'll figure it out we'll figure it
out you're still trying to get a lead
right
here
[Music]
you